One more project that I would like to
leave you with... that is what I am
planning to do next. And I haven't yet
talked about this. This is the first time that
I am saying anything at all about it.
What I am planning to do is to create
a calendar. There are a lot of those.
The Gregorian calendar for example. And the
calendars that we have are very regular.
They are more regular than the spin of
the planet. They're certainly more
regular than life on Earth. And so that
got me thinking about whether you could
have a different kind of a calendar.
A calendar that would in fact be true to
life in terms of the fact that it would
keep time according to how life was
lived on this planet. Well those
calendars are actually all around us.
They're called trees. And trees will grow
a ring every year. And the girth of that
ring is determined by climate, by
rainfall, weather patterns, and so forth.
But we don't tend to see them in that
way unless we saw them down.
And to me it seems that you could in fact
make a tree operate as a calendar by taking that tree--
and I am proposing a bristlecone pine,
a tree with a 5,000 year lifespan--
and putting milestones around it.
Well, not exactly milestones, but
"century stones." Or stones with a 500 year period
between stones, set at regular intervals
according to... if the calendar, if the
tree were to grow at the rate that it
is right now where would it be in 500 years?
At that point it will grow large enough
that because of its strength it will
turn over that stone. And a thousand
years... and so forth up to 5,000. But
of course it will fall out of sync.
It won't won't work out that that 500 years
will be the same 500 years as you have
marked on your Gregorian calendar. And
to me that is where it really
gets interesting. Because I don't know which
calendar in that case
we would say was right. I don't know
how we would account for time if we
had these two different kinds of calendars
that were simultaneously keeping time.
One of which was celestial; one of which
was abstract. And the other of which was
manifestly terrestrial and
was really about the world as we exist in it.
The world in which we are living in now.
So where to get a bristlecone pine?
Well it just so happens that I know some
people who have more than one of them.
The Long Now Foundation happens to
have this space... more than a space, it's
800 odd acres in Eastern Nevada:
Mount Washington. They bought it back in
the 01990s. And it just so happens to have
the world's largest bristlecone pine
forest in private hands.
This is the ideal space and I've already started
talking with The Long Now Foundation
about how we might implement this. To put
the calendar there that would be
able for the next five thousand years
to keep time on our planet.